[Musique]
les pcistes basse en son contraire qui
est vie sans doute facile à trouver le
bonheur n'existe que pour plaire je le
enfin je commence à douter d'en avoir
vraiment rêver est ce une envie parfois
je me sens obligé de le suspect n'est
plus à me pas compliqué d'être l'espagne
est plus zen
c'est pas compliqué
le spleen les plus à la mode le bonheur
la remplacer alors c'était un lundi
matin vous mais je pose mes affaires
bureau et les 8h15 et je fonce chez
magic
je reviens et d'un lecteur de dire quand
adversaire ballon mon mantra et autres
spin est la team had to death encore
frappé une bande de joyeux collègues qui
aime mettre du bonheur dans nos bureaux
sur vos réseaux sociaux
mais allez savoir pourquoi ce matin
cette initiative mais plutôt mal à
l'aise alors c'est assez rationnel j'ai
tourné chargé il ya un jour férié dans
la semaine je vais devoir bousculer vos
programmes doublée d'une petite aversion
pour les gardiens de made in china et
l'émouvant on ne se refait pas en fait
en poussant un peu plus loin je crois
que cette date d'anniversaire je n'ai
pas envie de la partager mon bureau avec
des collègues
c'est un moment assez personnel le
passage d'une dizaine pour moi cette
année et ce rapport à son histoire
familiale autant c'est quelque chose de
plus tôt ainsi comme le bonheur vous
savez cette notion un peu flou
d'ailleurs ça fait très longtemps j'ai
arrêté de me demander quelque chose
et que je cherche plutôt à savoir ce qui
me rend heureuse de chanter danser et
partager des bons moments avec les amis
avec la famille et plein d'autres choses
mais revenons à mon magasin de farces et
attrapes ce matin j'incarne la fonction
je suis fière comme je vis un sourire
sur le visage et j'accueille toutes les
personnes qui passent dans mon bureau en
plaisantant je promets même à un
ambassadeur happiness de garder ce
décorum pendant au moins une semaine car
il faut que le bonheur se voit il faut
que le bonheur circulent dans
l'entreprise alors si je vous raconte
cette anecdote c'est pour évoquer le
dilemme des balles
ce dilemme il est simple lorsque
l'entreprise ne met rien en place des
salariés sont au c 10 du sujet
en revanche lorsque l'entreprise mais
des dispositifs spécifiques beau temps
au travail en place elle est vite
suspecté de manipulation de mascarade
d'ailleurs j'en ai fait les frais sur
twitter al'annonce de ce type x alors
que faire
commençons par dire tout ce qui se dit
aujourd'hui sur cette injonction au
bonheur dans les essais sociologique
philosophique et retrouvons les
critiques autour des tifs active officer
autour des salles de shoot autour des
cafétérias des corps est gratuite
cette instruction au bonheur serait fait
pour cacher la production la poule la
volonté d'augmenter la productivité et
la pression
on mettrait sur les salariés en fait un
système managérial au présent se double
d'une autre explication c'est le report
sur l'individu de la responsabilité de
son épanouissement
alors que cet épanouissement devrait
être collectif lié à une responsabilité
managériale raincourt parcours
sociologique
j'étais à ses adeptes de ces idées
pourtant l'anecdote que je vous ai
raconté et beaucoup d'autres montrent
qu'ils demandent dans l'entreprise et
qu'il ya sans doute des besoins les
écarter ce serait être méprisant et sans
doute se couper aussi du terrain font
revenir aux origines de cette aspiration
au bonheur
vingt ans auparavant à la fin des années
90 la psychologie positive s'installe
partout dans toute la société y compris
à l'université et dans l'entreprise bien
sûr avec un angle dominant il faut voir
ce qu'il ya de positif chez l'individu
et lui faire confiance pour kid pour
qu'il accède lui même à son propre
bonheur qu'il crée lui même son propre
bonheur il suffit d'aller 1,9 nac
arpenté les rayons développement
personnel pour comprendre à quel point
il est facile d'être hors autoroute où
les jours vous avez trouvé des billets
de recettes
d'ailleurs honnêtement qui m'a jamais
traité sur ces petits opuscules magilton
fois qu'on a dit ça en tant que pro de
la com qu'est-ce qu'on en fait dans
l'entreprise car ces brigades du bonheur
vous donnerait presque des complexes
c'est le dilemme d'egypte vous savez les
gentils organisateurs des clubs de
vacances qui vivent aussi le sourire
un consul m h 24 tout en se demandant
pourquoi cette remarque est dans une
telle galère alors le positivisme
évidemment comme ça nous connaît les
spéciales du verre à moitié plein les
spécialistes des bêtes histoire c'est
bon nous le reproche assez d'ailleurs
pourtant nous ne sommes pas complètement
d'un livre d'un yves et nous savons bien
qu'en organisant par exemple une superbe
convention où tout le monde sera heureux
fier d'appartenir à cette entreprise
si les sujets d'inquiétude tels que les
déménagements les fusions les
restructurations ne sont pas abordés
nous risquons de créer de la frustration
du désengagement bien plus que du
bonheur en même temps ça vont faire le
job fermes pilotes dans nos métiers
c'est faire appel aux émotions positives
cerveau droit
nous voilà alors nous tomber s'ils nous
montrait des images extraordinaires de
salariés souriant se prenant dans les
bras pour lancer un nouveau produit pour
montrer la réussite l'obtention d'un
nouveau marché
beaucoup d'émotions positives pourtant
les émotions négatives reste là quand on
nous pas de choses voir où les évitons
et contournant ya sans doute un danger
dans ce processus
à vouloir créer une nouvelle échelle a
brutalement de la performance les chais
de la performance des émotions
alors stop avec de vouloir sans cesse
d'être et une image heureux se voir
festive de l'entreprise alors que
celle-ci par définition est le lieu de
toutes les complexités difficultés
économiques sociales potentiellement
contraintes réglementaires en montrant
cette image peureuse festif nous et
soyons d'effacer tous ces éléments
naturels alors et nous coupons du corps
social nous pose potentiellement d'une
communication authentique
une fois que nous avons ce a que faire
respirons calme le jeu nous avons
l'habitude ans comme devoir passer un
tas de dareta de tendance et nous en
saisir ou pas aujourd'hui c'est le
bonheur hier j'étais la participation
nous payons avec des drh avec les
cabinets de consulting & start peur
qu'ils ont engagés est accompagné sur
cette voie dire stop et revenir à nos
fondamentaux
les fondamentaux très simple qui
consiste à expliciter la stratégie de
l'entreprise pour que chacun chacune
s'en sentent partie prenante expliquer
les objectifs qui sont confiées par le
management
au contraire montrer la contribution à
un collectif c'est la vraie vie la vraie
mission les communicants et des
communicante et c'est ce qui va apporter
aux salariés
l'insatisfaction satisfaction ne semble
le mot juste satisfaction d'être utile
de se sentir partie prenante de
l'entreprise en fin d'année je travaille
dans le logement social
on peux vous préciser donc en fin
d'année une section à montfermeil
là tu lui n'était pas là nous n'allons
pas voir les misérables mais nous étions
à montfermeil pour une projection d'un
court métrage avec le réalisateur avec
les gardiens d'immeubles qui faisait
l'objet de ce court métrage et les
locataires lors de ce court métrage les
locataires se sont exprimés en
remerciant les gardiens
en montrant en expliquant d'autres en
donnant d'autres anecdotes pour
expliquer toute la plus value de ce
métier autant vous dire
cet événement était très simple donc
c'est évidemment sans ballon mais le
l'utilité des gardiens de ce métier
était et des battantes et lille a suffi
de la présence du maire de directrice
générale du management pour donner du
sens à leur métier et plus globalement à
toutes les équipes
alors laissons de côté les salariés qui
veulent vous apportez debab les cds sont
offerts mais les prends des lisiers
belle initiative mais ne prenons pas le
même chemin
responsable à la question que nous
devons nous poser les parent comment
rendre les gens heureux dans
l'entreprise mais plutôt comment faire
une communication qui a du sens et qui
est du tibet
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]